hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
in part three of arthur schopenhauer's
on the basis of morality he devotes an
entire chapter number 18
to what he calls the virtue of
loving-kindness virtue is tugend and
loving-kindness is
mentioned liba it's also translated as
philanthropy there's a number of other
words that we could use for this if
we're placing this in different contexts
we might call it benevolence as well
and he talks about
karitas this latin term that we
sometimes translate as charity agape
in greek as well and there's a lot of
different ways to
formulate this
at the start of the chapter he says
something quite interesting about where
we get these ideas historically now he
he also points out that in ordinary life
we do
recognize this and we do enact it as
well we don't necessarily need a
theoretical basis but it is worth
reflecting on
where this idea
made its way into
philosophical discussions of how we
ought to behave and relate to our fellow
human beings and so he tells us that
um the philosophers of antiquity and by
this he means greek and roman
philosophers recognize justice as a
first and fundamentally essential
cardinal virtue and they
coordinated it with three others that
were unsuitably chosen he says what are
these well you know wisdom courage
temperance those are not in
schopenhauer's view
cardinal virtues and then he says on the
other hand they did not set up
philanthropy or loving-kindness
as a virtue and he brings up several
cases plato who rises to the greatest
heights of morality gets only as far as
voluntary disinterested justice
he says it is true that philanthropy has
existed at all times in practice and in
fact but it was first theoretically
mentioned formulated as a virtue by
somebody else who
by
christians by jesus the teacher and
those who
followed him he says that it was
formulated as the greatest of the
virtues and extended even to enemies
by christianity this is christianity's
greatest merit he goes on to say
although only in respect to
europe
not
asia and why not asia schopenhauer
incidentally is one of the
you know philosophers in the west who's
really taking indian philosophy
seriously
and so he brings up the veda the dharma
sastra
the puranas and and other texts and he
talks about the teaching of the buddha
sakyamuni and so what we've got here is
in in non-western philosophy
specifically in india we've got hindu
and buddhist teachers and texts that are
saying that this
this comportment of loving kindness
or
philanthropy is something quite
important so we've got two different
we could say sets of traditions bringing
it up and formulating it you know
bringing it into
cultures
and he does say to be strictly accurate
we must mention that traces
of a recommendation to loving kindness
are to be found even among the ancients
for example
in cicero de finibus
on the moral ends in book five it's
interesting he doesn't mention another
work by cicero which does touch upon
this but which frames it is part of
justice namely um on duties uh book one
where there's a significant discussion
of this he brings up pythagoras
according to yamblachus in the life of
pythagoras and he says oh that's you
know there there were some traces of
this but if you compare
even what cicero is saying to what we
see in
christianity cicero's understanding of
this or cicero's advocacy of this is
considerably limited it's you know there
are duties to enemies but they're not
duties of benevolence right
so
christianity and hindu and buddhist
we could say texts traditions are
articulating something
more important after we get through this
historical discussion where did this
make its way into culture into
philosophy we get to an analysis
he says
another suffering
in itself and as such
becomes my motive
what it is that is
motivating me to do things and how does
it do so
by compassion mitt lied literally
suffering with the other person this is
one of the three main
incentives or motivations that
schopenhauer identifies as driving us
human beings and so
this is how compassion
shows itself in this comportment or
virtue
of loving kindness and it tells us a
number of important things about this
the first thing that he wants to stress
is what he calls the positive
character of the actions so this is how
it differs from
justice justice is basically
hands off don't injure other people
right it's kind of a negative
respecting the rights of others for
example and
loving kindness goes beyond this loving
kindness does things that are
that are positive
you look at the other person and you
help them you
see their suffering you see their pain
you see their distress
and you try to remove it or relieve it
or do something about it so
feeding the hungry person might not
actually be a matter of justice it could
very well
be a matter of loving kindness
now of course if you go to somebody to
take away their sandwich you're
committing injustice but going to
another person and giving them a
sandwich just out of the blue because
you can tell that they're hungry
you know asking them hey you want to
come into this store and i'll buy you a
sandwich
that would be loving kindness that's
showing this positive
character
that he is talking about it he says
compassion not only
not restrains me from injuring another
it even impels me to help him it
motivates me to help the other person
and i think another really important
trait about this
he talks about sacrifice he says i will
be
induced by this purely moral motive
to make a greater or smaller sacrifice
for another's needs
or
distress because i feel i keenly
participate
in this distress that they are feeling
and then he says this sacrifice may
consist in an expenditure
a
giving a using
of my bodily or mental powers on this
person's behalf
so i'm
giving of myself
or of the things that i have he gives
examples of this the loss of property
you know if i'm giving a beggar some
money i don't have that money anymore
right
i mean if i am just thinking about well
you know what comes around goes around
i'm not really being compassionate in
that case we'll talk about that in a bit
if i am giving it to them and i'm not
expecting anything in return i've lost
something so
property
health
you could be putting your health at risk
you could be sacrificing your health for
other people freedom you know the
capacity to do what it is that you
choose to do we can bind ourselves to
other people even life itself and he
gives you know as as examples of these
sorts of things throughout the work a
number of interesting ones
a hero who
you know says take care of my wife and
children and then goes out and grabs all
the spears to himself killing himself in
the process so that the uh freedom
fighters can you know beat the the
mercenaries
that's one example it could also be
giving your life over time it ties in
with health right
to another person to preserve their own
life it could be
choices that you have to make in a
difficult situation who's going to stay
on the lifeboat who's going to
eat the food that's
available in the famine right so
sacrifices are important
he also talks about and this is a very
interesting formulation
purely objective aim
what is it that we're really
aiming at
um what is it that we're really
trying to do he says um
[Music]
we have cases where my my aim could be
something other than the purely
objective one of wanting to know the
other person is helped is rescued from
his need in distress or is freed from
his suffering and absolutely nothing
else but this only with the purely
objective aim have i really shown that
loving kindness karitas agape the
preaching of which is the great and
distinguishing merit of christianity and
he goes on and he talks about this
biblical precept in matthew
don't let the you know the one hand know
what the other hand is doing when you're
giving right don't do it so that you
look good or so that you feel
good or something like that he says that
these are based on a feeling of what
i've deduced here
namely that another's distress alone and
no other consideration
must be my motive if my action is to
have
moral
worth
and he says the vedas also give us the
higher inspiration they assure us that
whoever desires any reward for his works
is still wandering on the path of
darkness and is not yet ripe for
deliverance and he's got this wonderful
passage here that i think really
clarifies this
if anyone were to ask me what he gets
from giving alms my answer would be this
that the lot of that poor person
is made so much the lighter otherwise
absolutely nothing
if this is of no use and no importance
to you then your wish was not really to
give alms but to make a purchase and in
that case you're defrauded of your money
you didn't get a good bargain right
if however it's a matter of importance
to you
that the person who is oppressed by want
suffers less
then you've attained your object from
the fact that he suffers less and you
see exactly how far
your gift is rewarded so the the
aim the object of charity of
you know loving kindness however we want
to put it
is that the other benefit
that the other is harmed less that the
other
has their needs attended to that the
other has their distress
alleviated at least to some
degree so this is this is
extraordinarily important right and now
he also says how is this actually
possible and this is where we get a very
interesting way of formulating it
schopenhauer rejects the idea he talks
about there being an identification in
compassion but it's not an
identification in that i imagine myself
as that person
and like everything between us is
totally broken down and i'm just helping
myself that would actually still be
egoistic
i recognize that they are not me
and i am the one who is acting they are
the one who is
being benefited but i also
feel
and participate in
their suffering
it could be a suffering of all sorts of
things it could be
need it could be
unsatisfied desires it could be
humiliation it could be sadness it could
be grief whatever it happens to be
i participate in it i feel it but i
don't feel it
in me i recognize i'm not the one who's
actually
being harmed they are
and i
feel it in them
it's a way of access
you could say
to another
person
and he says that you know we don't
actually
have a
complete explanation for this the
occurrence is mysterious it is something
our faculty of reason can give no direct
account of can give an indirect account
we just did right there
and its grounds cannot be discovered on
the path of experience and yet it
happens every day everyone has often
experienced it within himself even the
to the most hard-hearted and selfish he
says it is not
unknown it's actually there in all of us
at least in potential this uh compassion
with other
people so i share in the others
suffering in them in
who they are
right so this is a very
important to
consider
he also talks about the possibility of
doing things that
seem benevolent or charitable or loving
kindness but they're they're actually
not why not well think about the example
that we just gave before somebody says
why should i be charitable to a beggar
and you're like
so that you help them out and they're
like yeah but why should i help them out
at that point
there's something they're not getting
and they're being motivated by egoistic
uh you know
imperatives uh impulses motives however
you want to talk about it you could be
motivated by egoism a lot of people will
give to charity so that they get a tax
break so that they look good to the to
other people feel good about themselves
right there's all sorts of possible
motivations feeling a sense of guilt
right
so you know this is what often is the
case he says
as soon as i have my own wheel however
remote and indirect and view and doing a
good deed and when i'm urged by
considerations of reward in this world
or the next or by the attainment of high
esteem or by the reflection that the
person i help may someday be able to
help me in return or otherwise to serve
or benefit me finally when i'm urged by
the thought that the maxim of
magnanimity or charitableness must be
upheld because it may one day benefit me
in short this is the case whenever my
aim is anything other than this purely
objective aim i'm being driven by egoism
or another possibility i can also be
driven by
the clearly anti-moral motive of malice
right i can give to somebody else i can
do something for somebody else
just to tick somebody else off to make
them jealous to make them angry or
something along those lines he says
i can do good to one person to annoy
another who i do not benefit or to make
the other person's sufferings more acute
or even to put to shame a third who does
not benefit the first or
by my action to humiliate the man who i
benefit there's all sorts of ways of
being seemingly
loving kind or benevolent or
philanthropic which are really
to hurt somebody else
now the last thing that i think is
really worth bringing up here and it's a
case that we should consider
schopenhauer says that this doesn't just
happen on the individual level it can
happen on a much larger scale
and he brings up the very interesting
case
of how the british
ended
slavery says that there was long
deliberation and difficult debates the
magnanimous british nation gave 20
million pounds to purchase the freedom
of the negro slaves and its colonies
this it did with the joy and approbation
of the whole world whoever feels
inclined in an eye the motive of this
fine action on a grand scale is
traceable to compassion in order to
ascribe it to christianity should bear
in mind that the whole in the whole of
the new testament no not one word is set
against slavery at the time the thing
was so universal and you know you could
even quote the bible about that and he
says so what was really going on here
was a
um you know benevolence or loving
kindness on a very large scale does that
mean that every single person involved
in it or the owners who are benefited by
being paid this money were
you know necessarily acting out of
motives of loving kindness no he's not
asserting that but he is holding out the
possibility for some large-scale
actions policies in fact
through deliberation of people making
the arrangements to
be motivated by compassion towards
loving kindness so this
is a very important area of
schopenhauer's ethics he conceives of it
as a virtugen
and he thinks that it drives a lot of
stuff but it must always be motivated by
compassion or it has no moral
significance or negative moral
significance
it doesn't serve anything good if it is
motivated by compassion
even if perhaps the results don't work
out the way that you want it does have
positive moral value
you